it's the first image if you have any
pagosian since he led a mutiny heading
towards Moscow the post on the telegram
app says the Wagner head is in Belarus
the private mercenary group is training
belarussian soldiers but it's likely
they'll also keep fighting in Ukraine
Vladimir Putin told a Russian newspaper
despite the Revolt he offered to let
Wagner mercenaries continue fighting as
long as progosian wasn't involved
Ukrainian President says at the moment
there is no large-scale threat from
Belarus and that full concentration is
on the front
ukrainians are trying to reclaim
territory in the south and east but
Russians are said to be well protected
in deep trenches surrounded by fencing
and mines
for the ukrainians to gain any grounds
push the Russians back they have to go
through these incredible defenses that
have been set up three four five or six
different lines that's where these come
in
cluster Munitions could come into play
they're now in Ukraine's possession
courtesy of the U.S both Russia and
Ukraine have used these rounds in the
past they hold lots of smaller
explosives that are released midair and
fan out some don't explode right away
more than 100 countries have banned them
including Canada and the man who
shepherded the 1996 land mines treaty is
outraged once you unleash the dogs of
war you're never sure where they're
going to run to well I think we've
Unleashed this whole issue of using this
terrible weapons in fighting off
invading Russian forces Ukraine has been
using an estimated 8 000 rounds a day
the United States are supplying those
cluster Munitions is that we we
collectively the West can't Supply
Ukraine with enough conventional
artillery shells the way it could have
been avoided is if Mr Trudeau and other
NATO leaders had grown the spine earlier
to to send Ukraine the muscle it needed
and the grinding protracted War isn't
likely to end soon
Crystal gemancing Global News London